(audience clapping)
Hi, Oprah.
Hey, Dr. Perry,
good to see you again.
I was listening and I have to say,
isn't that OW something, unbelievable.
(Oprah laughing)
(gasps) Yes, well, I think
that the fact that you teamed up
speaks volumes
in about each of you.
And Dr. Perry, you've been an expert on childhood
development and the impacts of trauma on our brain
for the past 30 years.
And they say that there's a misconception
that trauma is this big unwelcomed tragic event
in our lives.
But do you think that it has to be big
or can it be moments throughout?
Everybody has a journey,
and on that journey, there's just no way
that you're gonna get through that unscathed.
So and as you said,
it doesn't always have to be this big catastrophic disaster
that everybody would point to and go, "Oh, that's trauma."
Yes, exactly.
More often, it's smaller things, right?
I mean, it's the things,
in "Oprah", and I've talked about this a lot,
we talked about this in the book.
But one of the most important things
about being a human being is feeling like you belong.
Like you belong in your family,
you belong in your community,
you you belong in your culture.
And if you get signals from your parents
or you get signals from your classmates
that you don't belong,
and those signals might come from something
like their implicit bias, that you're the wrong religion,
or you're the wrong skin color,
or you have the wrong ethnicity.
And if you get these nonstop little stressors
that you have no control over,
over time, that changes the systems in your body
that control stress.
And it can really have profound impact
on your mental health and on your physical health.
And when it comes to the brain,
can we rebuild what wasn't there?
Can we regulate, relate, and reason?
Yeah, well, the good news is that the brain is changeable.
And if given opportunities,
with sufficient repetition,
these systems in our brain that have been impacted
by our past experiences, they can begin to normalize
and become more typically regulated.
And ultimately,
you can heal.
Oprah said something about how there is good news
and we can take the holes that have been given
and bestowed upon us in our life and make them our strength.
Make them the cues in which how we treat other people.
Uh-huh.
Has there been a point, Oprah in your life
where somebody else had to fill those holes?
I think for me, that would, those were teachers.
I wouldn't be who I am,
that is why I have such a love for teachers.
I mean, if somebody tells me a teacher,
I literally started like, "Oh, you're a teacher."
Because in my life, teachers were my saviors.
When I went to school, I was important.
And that is where my sense of self and worthiness came from.
Not from my family, but from other people.
And so Bruce said, and this is true of all of us.
Nobody makes it out here alone.
And our connectedness to other people,
our relationships with people who can see us,
all you need is one person who fully sees you and believes.
And that's the thing that you hold on to.
That you are seen, you are valued, and that you matter.
And
what I realized,
I didn't even share this with you, Dr. Perry.
What I realized
is that Gayle was my regulation.
Makes me wanna cry now thinking about it.
Every night after the show, I would come home,
and I would have these sessions with Gayle
where we talked about what happened on the show.
or didn't happen in the show.
We're gonna,
And that was the way I kinda regulated myself.
So I would talk to Gayle before bed,
and then I would be calmer.
And it wasn't until I not only was co-authoring the book,
but actually went back and reread the book
that I realized, "Oh, Gayle was what I use
for my sense of regulation."
And is still the person in my life.
I have probably three people in my life
who are gonna tell me the truth no matter what.
I thank you both so much for your time.
And I love this book so very much.
"What Happened To You" by Oprah Winfrey
and Dr. Bruce Perry is out now available
everywhere books are sold.
And each one of our BFFs
will be receiving a copy of this book.
(audience clapping)
I wanna just say that Dr. Perry and I
have been also, for the past two years,
along with Prince Harry and Apple,
we've been working on this mental health series
that's coming out in May on Apple.
And
what our mental well-being,
our mental health being able to rise
to the best of yourself is a part of my goal in life.
And now as I
get to spend my days doing exactly what I want to do.
I mean, I still continue to be
the kind of person who wants to use my life
in order to help other people have the best of theirs.
'Cause I think I have just the best life ever.
And I think that comes from doing the work,
peeling back the layers.
And that certainly begins
with looking at what happened to you.
So thank you for an opportunity to talk about it
and to share it with other people.
Thank you.
And look at the conversation you had
with Megan and Prince Harry.
I believe that will change the world
and it will change the future.
So with each conversation, may you make history as well
Well, thank you.
(Oprah claps)
changing the future.
Thanks to Oprah and Dr. Perry.
And if you'd like to attend
Oprah and Dr. Perry's virtual book tour,
visit our website at TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
for all the information you need.
Thank you so much.
Thank you guys!
(upbeat theme music)